you may not believe it but this is
really private McGillicuddy and his
unusual activity is quite a surprise
face mask a burglar disinfectant looks
like he's preparing for an important
operation and again she's going to wash
his mess gear although he's knocking
himself out with all this surgical
etiquette there's good reason for it
Mack is not taking any more chances so
draw up a foxhole and we'll tell you
what
once upon a time McGillicuddy
ignored the commandment thou shalt
carefully and faithfully wash time miss
Gere both before and after meals or
verily if thou become negligent in this
habit thy gut shall be like nuts in a
what rope so while the other man went
through their usual routine of cleaning
their mess gear in scalding hot soapy
water
McGillicuddy would stash his lazy butt
under a coconut tree and wash his gear
in his own way
she over it looks clean but it isn't you
can't clean your mess gear by licking it
no that just makes it look pretty
here look at it through this magnifying
glass you see those little spots there
bits a decayed food no telling how long
they've been there now watch closely
humane e that is a germ you ain't seen
nothing yet
take another gander now watch a multiply
2 4 8 16
if you haven't been washing you mess
gear properly you've been eating those
dirty microscopic scavengers
well that's more like it
and that isn't all you've gotta wash it
again before you eat otherwise stringy
insects like this fly for instance we'll
follow it up again maybe he's just been
to the Privy maybe your garbage duck and
undoubtedly is packed with dysentery
germs if you are not careful
McGillicuddy you will be too what's more
hey knucklehead wake up I'm talking to
you there's a fly on your mess gear
don't forget to wash that thing before
you eat
that's right Mac first in line last and
brains let them pile all that good
wholesome food on top of those germs
remember Mack
ten so kiddies that is the story of
private McGillicuddy and the bad little
germs and how we learned to wash his
mess gear and live happily ever after